I went hiking on Phoenix mountain I put
in my ways hiking it said Phoenix
Mountain I go to Phoenix Mountain
whatever that is
there's fire trucks everywhere so Jim
very general I know very general by the
way hiking Phoenix mountain very done
and you like other words and there's all
these fire trucks I'm like what's going
on well a woman had climbed to the peak
and then who that fellow yeah she got
she got all she had some cactus the
fireman comes down and I go she gonna be
right he goes nah bad
oh my god Jesus I go if she's gonna live
yeah yeah she'll live but she's gotta
get operated on she busted her stupid
shoulder you hurt her back I go well you
know he just like happens all the time
like he's a fireman he's older as they
need idiot to go out there they're not
ready and they fall anyway she's gonna
be fine but there was a huge crowd so I
went off the beaten path drifting and I
followed this trail that seemed to go
and when you're out in Phoenix and you
see those giant cacti and it's just
stone and it's prehistoric now it was
all good but I started walking far out I
got a little spooked and I here's why I
got a little snoop here - well no
wearing Morales nice I should spooked
because my buddy Steve Rinella told me
that in Arizona you get you got your
mountain lion no problem got your
mountain I got your elk got your all
kinds of stuff okay yes I know you're
gonna say go ahead and get that Pepsi
was you got those everywhere now you got
you got the tarantula hawk every Trump
the I'm sorry I got my reading the
Pettis wasp that's Gaza Pepsi wasp
you're using there's the tarantula well
you're using the Latin but the layman's
term is that I'm chill at heart because
because they eat tarantulas so they see
a tarantula they're like mmm and they're
out there every month I'm seeing about
in sting in your abdomen bunch
you're gonna die that I'm and eat and
him out your face yeah yeah do you think
about it now that wasn't what I was
worried about okay if that guess what I
was worried about I got spooked it was
weird because I heard noises oh my god
can I guess again yeah Mexicans sir
no a man and I'm just we're just
brainstorming right of Mexican people I
don't know if there's a lot is out
thinking about migrants coming over so I
don't know maybe others try out its
cartel area okay well maybe they're
building a wall wasn't worried about
cartel members in the Phoenix will you
know this is a safe space
not for racist comments yes not braces
maybe you're worried you're the one
white guy in the desert you're worried
about tarantula hawk there's a bunch of
male mexicanos do what you see in my
eyes they do Mexicans would see in my
eyes my universal love for all humanity
and they would be like that guy right
there does one of us just want to build
a wall and they take me in and we'd hang
out and I'd give them some of my water
and we'd laugh okay now I guess may I
yeah I'm sorry I thought god damn it
well one guy Steve Rinella told me that
when they were tracking when he his
friends are tracking some Cougars
mountain lion with dogs all of a sudden
they look down the tracks and they said
tracks are too big its tracks are too
big he's on I seen a mountain what they
called the dogs off because apparently
for a lot of reasons mainly logging or
pressure it turns out that the agua de
agua know it's fighting its way up into
I assume that you got problems now
excute you don't run Oh Oh see now you
got a descent couple things I want you
to listen to me Mountain Lion not
worried about it because typically leave
you alone especially grown men women
kids young braum got some problem grown
man grown man barren unless you're
unless your [ __ ] not strong if your pee
told you drove I got my balls hang load
they're gonna feel they're gonna smell
my testosterone they know I'm gonna I'm
gonna take it to a fair for now now the
yeah guar 250 pound cat that's 250 pound
cat now I want you to think about lease
dog police talk 100 pound police dogs a
giant Shepherd take you down right away
no okay yeah bite you crusher look at me
you don't want to fight I don't like it
I mean you're tough you're a big
powerful guy if your life depended on I
might bet with you that you can kill one
of them
you've seen them hit a sleeve though cuz
the problem is when they bite you man
your arm shuts down I've seen other
times yeah that's what the shuts down
all right now you go to worldstar when
they send the dogs on some of these guys
guys if I don't fight them off the other
deal all right I believe that I believe
that are you I can believe that
now Sadler now the Agua hey hey what
it's 250 pounds no I don't want none
well you don't well how come G cuz it's
a predator kill you with its face
because it's its evolved with your face
yes you've all been killed giant animals
with its face and and by the way I hope
you understand one thing you're not
gonna see it you're not gonna see or get
you from behind oh yeah oh yeah and they
they move they they sound you what ready
your honor yah horse sounds like when
it's coming I can mimic it was on a bird
yeah guess what it sounds like ready
right dead yeah great
yeah that's good you're a good
impression 100% you do good you try to
get here they come again
now there's a pack of them how did he
ready everyone dead up and everybody see
that but you might go ah that's it cuz
he bites you in back yeah and then I
would just be it would be like this ah
that's it so my buddy's dad was the head
coach at North Carolina sit so Tar Heels
yeah and they were playing my hurricanes
so we I flew down in Miami
how long ago was this this was probably
six seven years ago flew down in Miami
and the night before and where we see
his dad we have dinner with him just
hanging it's dad you know so we're
having dinner talking all kinds of stuff
about we talk about the game or I was
you know see you in the morning so next
morning we go down and it's like four
seconds almost like you forget the level
of you know caliber programs these are
so he's like hey dad like how do we go
to the game and his dad looks around
because there's the team buses and
there's there's Florida Highway
patrolman motorcycles all these cargo
they're about to escort from the hotel
to the Orange Bowl is when the Orange
Bowl was still there yeah and terrible
state and he goes uh he talks to one of
the the cops he goes it's my son can
they and the guy goes just drive behind
the bus because I have a car and I'm
like okay and I'm forgetting what speed
we're gonna do this at because there's
buses I figure we're
to go like cruise dude these buses are
doing a hundred down 95 and I keep
falling behind a little bit because I
also don't want to run into the bus I
might look yeah man so I'm like I would
like dip out to you know 85 and that cop
behind me would be like dang it's like
go go go
so we're sitting there just flying and
they close like it's like a presidential
oh yeah you know roller skate yeah yeah
then as we pull off and we're pulling
into the Orange Bowl this local cop who
had cut stopped local traffic sees me in
the motorcade and he goes you there
because he thinks that I jump in on him
mm-hm and then I watch another cop go
like and then we just pull into the
Orange Bowl and I'm like holy [ __ ] like
I mean it was like the orange ball yeah
and it's also like I feel like I was
just in a race yeah I go legal and then
we just they just the but the team bus
goes down this tunnel and then they're
like I'll just park wherever okay okay
yeah we just pull in I'm like I just got
to go with an escort yeah 100 miles an
hour down look until I get their ass
whooped
no but it was actually [ __ ] I mean you
know cuz I'm with my my friend I
remember right before the half the slot
receiver dropped oh yeah touchdown in
the end zone he dropped it right through
his hand this is six years ago yeah and
then they ended up losing but they lost
a close game it was [ __ ] up Miami for
a while I mean they're getting a little
better now but for a while there they
kind of sucked bro I messed up I messed
up I knew you're coming in today and I'm
dressed like the Hamburglar I I just
want Versace to see this and be like you
know what we need a plus-size model we
when I [ __ ] up and I wore my goddamn
prison outfit oh yeah I'm regretting it
now your jeans are you yeah dude you
came dressed yet the sweet coat
no wonder your Versace you're talking
about man I'm pretty casual today but
I'll take it I'll take I'm yeah you're a
good-looking dude yeah bro get out of
you listen the companions Rogan Brian
we'll argue all the time who's the best
we can do in the UFC and I can just
Trump all of it and I go job and hat is
contractually tied to Versace damn over
I just Trump and I go oh cool
Versace you always show the love man I
get I get people always sending me those
videos bro and I'm like crying the whole
time I was the first team dimepiece
first team oh yeah yeah yeah I love it
man I'm kind of mad at Eddie Bravo
actually because me and Eddie we go way
back man and he's never showing the love
man he always seems but I think Eddie
has a type you know Eddie's Mexican I
think he kind of likes um I don't he was
saying it Robbie Lawler
I mean Rob you look like turds with ice
ax - Robbie Lawler he's not me Robbie
aren't even in this game yeah I'm kind
of like come on Eddie show the love man
but he might have a different time you
also might I want to you don't be too
biased cuz your boys